a sixth film in this franchise they are
currently working on a new final
destination movie they basically
announced that this is
in the works over at new line another
final destination movie final
destination six it's happening but after
covering near-death experiences
involving a plane crash highway pileup
roller coaster derail nascar disaster
and a bridge collapse what is in store
for the next installment of final
destination
could fan favorite character william
bloodworth be involved stay tuned
we're toying with having it take place
in the world of first responders emts
firemen and police perry said these
people deal with death on the front
lines every day and make choices that
can cause people to live or die we're
thinking that world might be an
interesting way into a final destination
movie and one which can also generate
unique set pieces in a very credible way
that's what series producer craig perry
had to say about the next final
destination but what i want to know is
how this film actually fits into the
canon
as someone who made a 30 minute video
where i basically put everything the
movies the books and comics into
chronological order i want to know where
this movie takes place the lore
is important to me the danger with
coming out with a new installment after
such a long gap is that these tend to
reboot the franchise which means we'd be
starting over
with all new lore however according to
an interview that series creator jeffrey
redick had with bd
that will probably not be the case with
the new final destination but it will be
set in a different world
so what does that mean a couple of
possibilities come to mind there's one
scene that has always intrigued me about
the original final destination and it's
not that part where death hides the
evidence of how it took out todd even
though nothing like that happens in any
of the other movies it's the part where
clear and alex sit on the beach together
look up at the stars and wonder what
life would be like if the disasters that
impacted both
of their lives had never happened
you think they're still up there somehow
flight went in are they still in flight
somewhere
are they safe i've thought a lot about
that somewhere
alex it exists that place where my dad
is still safe
i have no idea about this life here
where our friends are still in the sky
where everyone gets a second chance
it exists a world where flight 180
landed safely
exists what if final destination has a
split timeline
i would argue that it already does in
the original movie flight 180 went down
in the year 1999 but in each of the
sequels the events took place in 2000.
sure this might just be a retcon but
i've come to justify it as two similar
timelines where most of the events are
the same but in the sequel universe
everything takes place a year later
in fact the very concept of the series
seems to prove this to be true
the visions that each protagonist has
are what is supposed to happen but they
make changes they alter their destinies
to survive
each time this happens they create a new
split in the timeline the world where
they don't intervene it exists
they just don't go down that path now
the original five are assets they go
together i think there's no way to avoid
the next movie feeling different given
how much time has passed
it's like how you can put an old photo
filter on a new photo but it never feels
quite the same as a picture
that was taken during that era so making
a new continuity and a new timeline
branch could help alleviate that issue
and prevent the new movie from stepping
on the original five which could upset
fans we've seen this approach taken with
the halloween franchise basically
becoming a choose your own adventure but
the idea fits much better with final
destination where there's an in-universe
explanation for it
but what if i'm taking jeffrey reddick's
word a little too literally
maybe when he said it takes place in a
new world all he meant was that instead
of taking place in the world of
teenagers and young adults
it takes place in the world of emergency
responders and healthcare workers
speaking of which there's something that
i have to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we ever want to see final destination
six it's entirely dependent on ending
the kovid 19 pandemic and it's becoming
clear that the only way that's going to
happen is if the population gets
vaccinated i wanted to show my
experience so that everyone knows
there's nothing to be afraid of the
needle is so small you don't really even
feel it go in
i had a little bit of soreness for the
next day or two but it was never painful
the night after the second dose i was
feverish and had chills and a headache
but there was never a moment where i
felt scared because i knew this was the
vaccine going to work in my body to
protect me and the vaccine doesn't
contain the virus
how it works is the vaccine basically
contains the instructions that teach
your body how to produce the viral
proteins that'll be recognized by your
immune system
so if the virus sars cove2 enters your
system your body will already know how
to defeat it and prevent you from
getting copin 19.
it's basically your final destination
vision that can protect you from
disaster
because without the vaccine you could
become infected and nobody can predict
how sick you might get it could be mild
severe
or life-threatening not to mention other
symptoms that may last for months or
longer
and don't worry i made sure to run that
by a few medical professionals before i
said it out loud on the internet now i
certainly hope the new final destination
isn't about a pandemic though i think
this era represents a cultural shift for
us
horror was super popular from 2014 to
2018 with a lot of darker stories like
it's splits and a quiet place and i can
see the genre swinging back to something
more lighthearted much like how grunge
was the dark and serious dominant genre
of the 90s but it got a little bit too
depressing for people after kurt cobain
and that's when we started seeing the
snot nosed pop punk axe blowing up blink
182
some 41 green day 75 so i think the time
is going to be right for a final
destination six they've got the perfect
writers for it marcus dunstan and
patrick melton the guys who did soft
four through seven what makes saw such
an awesome franchise as the later
sequels don't suck that much for the
most part and they even honor the
continuity
it feels right for these guys to give
the same treatments to the other big
2000s horror series jeffrey reddick has
insisted that the sixth is not a reboot
but curiously mentions another world
the statement seems to contradict itself
i've explored what the movie might look
like if we take his words literally but
what if we take them figuratively
operating in the world of first
responders emt firemen and police
affords an interesting opportunity these
are all government workers that might
show up to the scene of a disaster and
are likely to have interactions with a
medical examiner could we see the return
of william bloodworth now when i made
the horror history episode on bloodworth
i theorized that he could have been an
escapee of death's design
this character is shrouded in mystery
and i always thought it would be cool to
explore his past and learn how he came
to be so knowledgeable about how death
operates i think it would definitely be
interesting to see a prequel where a
young bloodworth sees the horrors of how
his choices affect people's lives in the
front line and transitions to the role
of medical examiner so that he can be an
expert on death namely how to avoid
it if you want to hear more about my
theory click that video on the left and
if you love horror remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive